I don't know if it's a Nostalgia thing
now I just kind of miss the kind of old
school action scenes and uh I think I
think John wicker Works something in me
where I was like this is gonna work
something to me I wanna I Wanna Dance
you're not shoved up in that movie you
aren't watching the same movie
oh my God
just admit you want to [__]
I was like oh the the the gamer scene
you know you know what I'm talking about
oh dude that was showing the gamer scene
oh my God
just watch this watch before yeah I'll
skip two and three it's just like they
when they made that movie they were like
they must have known that no other movie
is gonna be able to compete they were
just like I mean no one has all movies
are canceled after John would fall until
John Wick five I think like this is it
gonna be a fifth one uh well they
actually well they teased they were I
don't know well
no I don't think so about that oh
perfect there will be a fifth one yeah
probably you're implying there was a
plot there originally for sometimes I
saw they announced that they were doing
it I was like what I don't know if
that's Twitter [__] but I was like
that this is gonna be a five hour move
but either way we're getting a bunch of
prequels and stuff and yeah that
wouldn't surprise me I I wouldn't want
the John Wick franchise to die I'd love
to know more about the universe which
you said didn't exist
you know I I thought I you know I
thought I didn't and I did and I was
just like this assassin universe is cool
it is a cool it is a really cool like
idea like conceptually I [__] love
the idea of this assassin Universe where
the rules of their unit they operate
within their own rules of their universe
but like it's kind of like for me it's
kind of like the you know kind of like
similar to horror the more you find out
about something the less the less scary
it becomes the more I find out about the
Assassin Universe the less the uh the
less most interesting and mysterious
that it is and the more that I'm I'm
like finding poking like holes in it
like why is this a thing you know why
why do things work like this this makes
no sense okay uh so yeah that was that
was a big thing but I would love to see
more John Wick I would love to see more
action movies
it's called John Wick 3.
oh
you have to watch that one oh yeah I'll
tell you what else I've been doing as
well okay
um I don't know why I've had so much
free time recently it's it's it's it's
it's weird it's mysterious
um I've been uh reading manga as well oh
what is that I've been doing I've been
doing doing a job yeah yeah what have
you been reading uh I've been reading a
manga called the climber and it's I
think
a [__] Masterpiece actually here we
go
like like a like a like an actual mask
and I don't know how I would actually do
this it is not a new one uh it is a
pretty old one uh Coco noito
oh yes I have read the first couple I
think of that yeah George read
everything Joe's read everything in
existence Joey has read it there's radio
bust if yes I've read the first couple
volumes okay so it's like let me let me
show you it's the best sports manga but
it's not really a sports Market it's a
it's the best sports manga I've seen
since uh I guess Sports media is incense
ping pong the animation
it is not a it's it's an anime about
someone who discovers like rock climbing
and free solo ink okay uh but it's not
it's not about that at all
um it like it's it's got a really
interesting story behind the story as
well because the first three volumes of
this manga is your typical like Shonen
Sports Shonen [__] kind of thing he
like enters this tournament he's he's
like he he has like high school Rivals
and then
so what happened is that about three
volumes in uh the writer so there was a
there was originally a writer and an
artist team up and the writer just left
the writer for some reason just left
leaving it to the artist to come up with
the story so around about three volumes
in it just completely shifts from this
stereotypical Shonen Sports manga to
this like life manga and if that was the
point I dropped it so that's why I
haven't this is why hearing this part is
the first time because when I read it I
remembered it as just oh it's a rock
climbing yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it's
got It's like one it's there's a few
manga that I've read that has made me
feel such like Deep Emotions as the
climber has and okay so when the rider
left it got better it got better so when
the dude stopped hiring the guy did it
himself he just started making better
wow maybe I'm girded yeah yeah yeah
because I'll do it myself yeah because
like you know slight spoiler um no not
really a spoiler but he just basically
just like stops the high school [__]
puts in a Time Skip and he's just like
okay yeah okay okay oh my God yeah yeah
it sounds amazing yeah he gets he gets
out of high school right and really
starts to
follow the Arts of rock climbing
properly and properly tries to like for
he not only like falls in love with rock
climbing but it really uses rock
climbing as a metaphor this sounds so
[__] pretentious but like that's
that's kind of why it's so good it uses
it as a metaphor for his own personal
troubles and [__] that you hate people
for and you hate Society for because one
of the most one one thing that I think
was genius that the artist uh one one
genius thing that the artists realized
about rock climbing
um and free soloing right is so the
basis of the final plot is that he wants
to climb K2 which is you know the second
highest second highest hardest mountain
to climb in the world uh so you know
there are plenty of climbers that have
died while mountain climbing rock
climbing Everest K2 whatever
um and so what he used so what he used
mountain climbing like a mountain
climbing team for is he realized that no
matter what you can't pretend to be
someone you aren't when you're in a life
or death situation on a mountain yeah
right so when people are in a life death
situation when your survival depends on
your team members and what they decide
to do whether they leave a man behind
whether they go out into a snowstorm to
try and find some shelter or some word
or something to help the team to survive
you see people who who what they really
are the raw people beneath all of the
[__] masks that they wear in society
and that leads to some of the most like
hardest hitting moments and [__]
amazing panels I've seen in a manga and
I then did not come into it expecting
that from a [__] rock climbing manga
it is honestly I think this manga is a
[__] Masterpiece and I've not heard a
single person talk about it so I'm I am
talking about it now if if you want to
see uh if you if you want to read
something that I think is uh really
really [__] underrated manga uh that
has some of the best Arts I've seen in a
long time like I'm sold I feel that's
the problem with like a lot of mangas
they're like because there's just so
much out there so much especially that
hasn't been animated that you know
obviously there are anime fans and there
are manga fans but I feel right now the
anime fans are kind of in the Forefront
talking about all the shows whereas the
manga fans are there but they're not as
the spotlight isn't put on them as hard
yeah yeah so when so there's more
instances of people finding these like
super unknown yet super amazing manga
series that no one talks about because I
feel the spotlight is not on there yeah
I just get stressed out knowing that so
many manga are ongoing because this
one's ended this one's it's ended
see when it's ended I'm like yeah okay
17 volumes I think okay 17 volumes yeah
that's a that's a hefty amount I'll say
half the amount I mean I I can't it's
here's the thing okay I kind of realized
this after reading reading the climber
which is uh obviously I know in my mind
that Manga and Anime are different I
thought my medium of preference was like
anime but reading reading this manga do
you ever read a manga and you're like
there is no [__] way this could ever
be a good anime
and it kind of made me realize it's
gonna sound like really pretentious like
art student talk but reading something
like the climber it made me feel like
when the difference between a manga and
an anime is a manga is basically like a
one-person team right and there's
something about the visual storytelling
you can feel when you turn around turn
on a panel and you see amazing artwork
you there's a there's something you feel
you almost feel like a connection to the
artist or to the writer well it's like
it's like looking at a painting at an
art museum right oh just like this was
knowing that this was made by one person
and like everything about this painting
derives from this one person's mind that
it came from yeah and when you you see
like a painting that like really
connects with you you you almost feel
like oh I understand what this person
was thinking I understand what kind of
person
whoever created this thing is right so
like it makes that connection extra
special yeah well and I totally get that
because like with anime it's a massive
team yeah there's lots of different
people involved including the Creator so
I feel it's
a little I'm not saying it's impossible
but it's a lot more difficult sometimes
no matter how good the anime is to have
like that type of personal connection
yeah right because this this doesn't
apply to every manga only like the
golden manga where I'm like holy [__]
I'm I'm reading something so I'm reading
something that's making me feel
it's emotions that few media have made
me being able to make me feel and I feel
like I am this is something that the
author is telling me personally not not
anyone else this is this is something
that he's trying to communicate with me
because like
um the other example I can think of
right is a villain Saga so villain Saga
is goaded in both anime and manga for
another episode today yeah yeah
another episode
it's one of the few manga that I feel
has gotten an adaptation that is oh it's
so good that is yeah that is goaded and
faithful and then I think back to my
experience with the villain Saga manga
and I think back to the experience with
the villain Saga anime and it's weird uh
because it's like a subtle difference
but in the villain Saga anime it almost
felt like it almost feels like hey
there's there's like uh there's there's
the fourth wall you know what I mean
there's the fourth one I'm watching a
piece of entertainment and I'm and I'm
appreciating the story but it felt like
when I was reading the manga I was like
holy [__] I'm actually feeling what you
you know because you you can Moorish
like trying to say it trying to tell me
and I can't put it I can't really put it
into words but it's like a different
kind of like appreciation between Manga
and Anime I think you just described why
so many people love manga yeah yeah I
think I get it now yeah I dude Finland
song anime is going so hard yeah my
favorite part of Vinland Saga other than
the uh it is absolutely an amazing piece
of media and you should watch or read it
whichever they're both they're both
amazing and you'll get whatever is my
favorite my favorite most favoritest
thing coming out of this everyone being
like maybe violence isn't that good an
anime
videos
then the Saga just said no to violence
and that's kind of cool how do we feel
about that boys
yeah it's kind of like how like I've
seen more people because in in Saga
right there is a big tonal shift in the
second part where violence kind of like
and the first part violence plays a very
big factor it's kind of glorify it's
kind of cool it's very hype and the
second part there's like they kind of
shifted to be like just extremely
oversimplified like violence bad not
good yeah and
I've seen like the ratio of comments
people actually complaining about the
second Arc to people complaining about
people going to complain about the
second Arc is is insane like there's I I
cannot find a single comment of someone
saying uh actually I found one or two
yeah like people saying the shock is
boring nothing's happening but I find so
much more comments you're being like
people just can't appreciate this
they're gonna call it boring I'm deep
because I get it and it's like shut the
[__] up no one cares it's a good show
everyone knows this is good I am that
person no because okay here's the thing
I think a lot of I think a lot of people
uh expected that uh just because that
was kind of the I mean I expected that I
suppose myself yeah yeah I expected that
too I think people were gonna be turned
off by it's funny because I've seen a
lot less negative comments in regards to
the anime because when the manga started
a lot of people just ended up dropping
it because they're like oh this is
boring now you know I think knowing that
even though it is still like half a year
until like kind of a bit of violence
happens yeah of anime run time thinking
the manga be excruciatingly long if yeah
well and the manga would be hoping for
yeah and in the manga there was no like
back reference right like no one could
go to an adaptation because this was the
original Source material where's the
anime all the manga fans are like coming
out of there like bunkers being like I'm
telling you it's good just wait stop
complaining [__] good man yeah I like
how we're talking about this after
martial arts and John wickened UFC maybe
violence isn't the answer guys guys oh I
mean I say that as well then I like I
immediately finished the villain Saga
episode I'm like all right time to watch
hell's Paradise it's just indiscriminate
violence yes that is just like violence
24 7. and I'm like this is great I
[__] love him from villain Saga
immediately said I'm watching next to
the health paradise and I was like this
is literally what they told me it's a
problem and I'm I'm still doing it